بدا رئيس الوزراء العراقي مالك اليوم
زياره رسميه الى موسكو يهيمن عليها زياده
على التعاون العسكري والتجاري الملف
السوري وقال المالكي ان زيارته تهدف الى
بحث المساله السوريه وفقا لحل سياسي
[موسيقى]
سنتوقف مشاهدينا مع هذا الخبر لنناقشه في
عنوانين رئيسيين
اولا اين يمكن ان تلتقي بغداد وموسكو فيما
يتعلق بمبادرات حل الازمه السوريه ثم كيف
يدير العراق علاقاته مع روسيا في ضوء
التزامات تحالفه مع واشنطن
[موسيقى]
تاكيد نور المالكي رئيس الوزراء العراقي
ان الملف السوري سيكون ضمن محادثاته مع
المسؤولين الروس يترافق في سياق او مع
سياق ت تتلاحق فيه
التساؤلات عن فرص واحتمالات التوصل الى حل
سياسي او مبادره في هذه اللحظات من الازمه
السوريه فيما بدا في الحديث عن صفقات
السلاح الروسيه للعراق بدا في ذلك صدى
للهواجس تمدد الحرب نحو دول الجوار
اخر زياره قام بها رئيس الوزراء العراقي
نوري المالكي لروسيا كانت قبل ثلاث سنوات
ونصف اي قبل اطلاله ما يعرف بالربيع
العربي الذي عصف بواحد من حلفاء موسكو في
العالم العربي هو القائد الليبي السابق
العقيد معمر القذافي حليف اخر ربما يكون
اكثر اهميه بالنسبه للعلاقات الروسيه هو
نظام الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد يصارع منذ
تسعه عشر شهرا للحفاظ على موقعه سياق يعيد
ترتيب ملفات المالكي في زيارته لموسكو وقد
استبقتها مقربون منه بالقول ان الازمه
السوريه ستكون واحده من ابرز الملفات التي
ستبحث ها بينما تحدث هو بشان تلك الازمه
عن ما سماه موقف العراق الداعيه الى ايجاد
حل سياسي للازمه السوريه والمعارض ل
انتهاج اسلوب العنف والتسلح سبيلا لذلك
الحل وقال المالكي ان العراق لم يتدخل في
سوريا لمصلحه النظام ولا لمصلحه المعارضه
المسلحه كما سماها ولعل هذه التصريحات
والمواقف التي تتقاسم بغداد بعضها مع
موسكو تكون خلفيه مناسبه ببلوره ما قد
يحمل شكل مبادره بشان سوريا كان العراق قد
كشف عنها متضمنه وقف العنف من قبل جميع
الاطراف المتنازعه وتنظيم انتخابات جديده
وتشكيل حكومه انتقاليه مثل هذه الافكار
كانت قد تضمنتها المبادره العربيه التي
عرفت اكثر باسم مبادره كوفي عنان وتبدو
اساسا مشتركا الى حد كبير بين الموقفين
العراق والروسي من حيث تركيزها على الخيار
السياسي للتسويه
على الصعيد الثنائي ماذا يريد رئيس
الوزراء العراقي من دوله روسيا لم تتميز
علاقتها مع بغداد ك تميزها في عهد صدام
حسين النقيض تماما لنظام رسميا وعلنيا انه
يريد ما سماه احياء العلاقات بين البلدين
في المجالات الاقتصاديه والتجاريه
والعسكريه الحديث عن صفقات الاسلحه مع
روسيا في ظل علاقات متميزه مع الولايات
المتحده يدرجه البعض في اطار تنويع مصادر
التسليح ومحاوله الابتعاد عن الاطفال
السياسي والعسكري لموقف دوله بعينها
ويعتبره بعض اخر جزء من هواجس العراق من
احتمالات توسع الازمه السوريه
في المقابل ما تريده موسكو من تقارب مع
بغداد ينطلق من العوده استراتيجيا وعلى
صعيد التعاون الى دوله مهمه العراق تقع
بين حليفين لموسكو ايران وسوريا يصعب
التكهن بما لا ت الاوضاع فيهما مجهول قد
تصب زياره ال بالك الحاليه لروسيا في
ضروره الاستعداد له
ولمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من بغداد
الدكتور علي اجل اه النائب في مجلس النواب
العراقي عن كتله ائتلاف دوله القانون
وينضم الينا من موسكو عباس خلف مستشار
معهد الدراسات الاستراتيجيه الروسيه ومعنا
من واشنطن السفير جيفري السفير الامريكي
السابق لدى العراق نرحب بضيوفنا من بغداد
وموسكو وواشنطن
وابدا معك من موسكو اه استاذ عباس خلف
يعني كيف او تتعامل موسكو الان مع ما يبدو
انه مبادره عراقيه لحل الازمه السوريه
اه موسكو تحاول ايجاد لاعبين محليين في
المنطقه من اجل الدفع ب ما تسميه بالحل
السياسي
ولكن يبدو ان الحل السياسي بات متاخرا
وحتى ال
المبادره العراقيه هي متاخره جدا لان سقف
المطالب لكلا الجانبين اي المعارضه
والنظام
فقد نسفت تماما والكل يبحث عن ضرب القاضيه
يمثلها بخدمه اه انا اعتقد ان هنالك اه
بدايه محور جديد يضم كل من طهران وبغداد
ودمشق بدا يتشكل وبدعم من موسكو الذي التي
ترى بانه اه سيقاوم ال اه المحور التركي
وكذلك دول الخليج العربيه اه وموسكو تستغل
هذا المحور من اجل انهاء الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه و للتفرغ في اه جمهوريات اسيا
الوسطى وابعاد الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
اي ان هنالك مصالحه سياسيه تحرس موسكو
تحرص موسكو على الحفاظ بها خاصه وان
النظام السوري هي اخر قلعه لمصالحها في
منطقه الشرق ال اه في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
وانهيار هذا النظام سيكون ايضا له
انعكاسات و و مردودات كبيره على الوضع
العراقي المرح العراقي الجيش اه فلهذا
السبب نرى انه موسكو ترحب
ولكن
نعم اه فقط استاذنك لا تحول الى بغداد
لانه الان معنا من بغداد
الدكتور علي
في مجلس النواب العراقي عن كتله دوله
القانون على كان تحدثنا عن ما يحمله في
الواقع رئيس الوزراء العراقي نوري المالكي
الى اه موسكو اللي طرحه كمبادره او كحل
للازمه السوريه
شكرا مسائل مسار المشاهدين والمشاهدات
والضيوف في الحقيقه اه الرئيس المالكي مضى
بالزياره بدعوه رسميه من الرئيس بوتين واه
رؤيته اه يعني الازمه السوريه هي ليست
مجمل الزياره ربما تكون جزء من هذه
الزياره الرؤيه الرئيسه هي علاقات العراق
الدوليه والتوازن المطلوب فيها حتى لا
يحسب العراق على معسكر واحد غربا وشرقا
ولذا بعد علاقات وطيده بالولايات المتحده
والمحور الغربي جاءت العلاقات في الصين
وكوريا واليابان
واليوم موسكو
نعم
السلاح والملف السوري حدثنا عن الملف
السوري ماذا يحمل معه كحل لون المالكي
يعني اه رؤيتنا واضحه للملف السوري التي
يحملها دوله الرئيس المالكي هي اولا اننا
لان حيث اي طرف عن التدخل بالشان السوري
تسليح ا او حتى تدخلا اخر في الشان
الداخلي نحن في العراق عانينا ونعرف ماذا
يعني تدخل الاشقاء الاعداء في شؤون بعضهم
البعض ولذلك اه رؤيه الرئيس المالكي ان
يكون الحل السوري السوري التي تدخل دول
المنطقه بتسليح ي من الطرفين وان
يعني يجبر الجميع على الجلوس الى طاوله
المفاوضات للوصول الى حل بدون السلام
لكن كيف سيتحقق ذلك برايك ما هو التصور
العراقي لجمع الاخوه السوريين كما تقول
لحل الازمه بينهم يكون الحل سوريا سوريا
كيف
يعني اولا رئيس كل الاطراف من انه يستطيع
ان يعتمد على عامل خارجي
نحن مشكلتنا في القضيه السوريه ان كل
الاطراف تبكي على دول في المنطقه واحيانا
على اه الصراع الدولي الامريكي الروسي
ولذلك نحن نعتقد في العراق من الاطراف
جميعا ينبغي ان لا تتوهم انه بالامكان ان
تظل الامور على ما هي عليه
ايضا كل الاطراف نعم لكن روسيا عامل خارجي
روسيا ايضا عن الخارجيه في الازمه ال ال
ال
نحن نعلم ذلك ولذلك مثل ما تحدثنا مع
الاصدقاء الامريكيون ما قلنا لهم ان
التدخل السعودي القطري التركي الامريكي
وفق هذه الرؤيا سيؤدي الى كارثه ويزيد من
سفك الدماء نقول الروسيين ايضا هذا الموقف
نحن نعتقد ان على الاطراف جميعا لا تتدخل
تسليح ا في الشان السوري ابدا وان يترك
المبعوث الدولي العربي
النظام السوري طيب دعني دعني انتقل الى
سفير جيمس جيفري يعني الان الملف السوري
محمولا
العراقيه الى ما اذا روسيا كيف ترى واشنطن
ذلك
اولا اشكركم على استضافتي ان الولايات
المتحده امريكا ليس لديها اي مشكله مع
رئيس الوزراء
المالكي ان عقد علاقات جيده مع موسكو في
العراق ما زالت تحت الفصل السابع وقرار
مجلس الامن وتقييد اته وهناك بعثه الامم
المتحده كبيره دعمها مجلس الامن تقوم بعمل
جيد في العراق وبالتالي فالعلاقات الجيده
مع موسكو مهمه واذا ما نظرنا الى تكوين
المجموعه التي صاحبت رئيس الوزراء اذن
الوزير لوزير خارجيه وزير دفاع او وزير
الطاقه ليست ان هناك علاقات قويه يفكرون
بها مع الشركات الغاز والنفط التي نشطت
جدا في جنوب العراق والسيد المالكي قد
يهتم بالشراء بعض اسلحه الاسلحه من
الواسعه من موسكو و و و مناقشه الوضع في
المنطقه كل من العراق وروسيا اه يهتم جدا
جدا على حول الوضع في سوريا وان الناس
وبعضها وضيفكم حتى الليله قالوا هناك وحده
مصالح بين البلدين انا لا اعتقد ذلك اعتقد
العراق لا يريد حصوله فوضى في سوريا بينما
اه روسيا الجانب الاخر تزوج السوريين
بالسلاح وان عائله الاسد قريبه من ال اه
الروس منذ زمن بعيد
كذلك الدكتور علي لا يعرف ان الدكتور
المشاكل الكثيره مع الاسف وخاصه الى وجود
مقاتلين اجانب كان ياتون من سوريا للعراق
طيب ما رايك بهذا الكلام
خلف واه في الواقع انما يؤكد ايضا
المستشار ال المالكي ان سياسه العراق في
سوريا اه يعني الا تؤثر على علاقاتها مع
واشنطن الى اي يعني ما هي الرساله التي
يغطيها لموسكو
اه اليوم السيد المالكي في مؤتمره الصحفي
الذي عقده او في محاضره سماها في مقر
اقامته قال اننا ان ننفتح على الدول
الاخرى وخاصه في الت في التسليح ولكن لان
ان تفتح بشكل كبير اي ان الممنوعات لا
تزال قائمه على بغداد خاصه في مجال
التسليح ونوعيه التسليه فسيدي المالكي ذكر
ان ناس نستورد بعض الاسلحه التي تخص
مكافحه الارهاب ونحن نعرف ماذا هي هذه
الاسلحه اسلحه متوسطه وخفيفه
اه بالنسبه لل بالنسبه
للملف السوري الملف السوري موسكو تحتاج
الى تفعيل دور ال اللاعبين الاقليميين اه
من اجل ايجاد حل ولكن هذه هذا الحل يبدو
مستحيلا لان ال المشكله في في دمشق اخذت
طريق اللاعوده في مساله الحل السياسي
ولعلنا نتذكر فشل جميع اه اه الوسطاء في
هذه ال هذه المساله اه بغداد لاتزال كما
اه ذكر السفير الامريكي تحت الفصل السابع
ولهذا السبب لا تتمتع ب اراده سياسيه
كامله اما بقضيه النفط والغاز فهي مساله
لان هذه الحقول النفط والغاز تعمل فيها
روسيا من الاتحاد السوفياتي و منذ اواسط
السبعينات من القرن الماضي موسكو تسللت
مره اخرى الى العراق واعاده نفوذها
بترحيب امريكي لانه لا تزال الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه اه ت اه ت ت لزم الكثير
من الملفات ولعل وصول لواء لواء من قوات
المارينز الامريكيه ل تفتيش الطائرات
الايرانيه
اه في هذا ال في هذا الوقت بالذات يدل على
شاشه سياده العراق في الوقت الحاضر اريد
ان اضيف اه مساله اخرى ان ال ان ايران هي
الان العلاقات الروسيه اه اه العراقيه
زياره السيد المالكي اتت مباشره بعد زياره
وزير الدفاع الايراني الذي قام بزياره الى
بغداد والتقى بالمسؤولين جميع او في
بيوتهم وهو اه مره اخرى اه يؤشر على عمق
التاثير الايراني في اتخاذ القرار السياسي
في بغداد بالاضافه الى قيام اه اه ما يسمى
البحريه ال اه القوات البحريه في الحرس
الثوري الايراني اي انه ايران ايضا تحتاج
الى حليف اخر منصب اذا اه الى اه انهار
النظام في دمشق فانها تحتاج الى مصاد اخر
لكي لا يصل التاثير اليها خاصه وان واشنطن
قد وضعت ايران على النار الهادئه ب عن
طريق العقوبات الاقتصاديه المعطل دكتور
دكتور علي يعني اي مصداقيه لهذا المسعى
الذي يقوم به اليوم اه ال رئيس الوزراء
العراقي نوري المالكي في موسكو عندما نعلم
ان حامل هذه المبادره او هذا الطرح حليف
للنظام السوري والالوان المتجه اليه وهو
موسكو ايضا حليف للنظام السوري فنحن امام
حليفين لسوريا وبالتالي قد يكون اي مسعا
ايضا الى النظام السوري
نعم اتفق معك ان العراق حليف لسوريا لكن
ليس حليف لطرف في الصراع كما هي بعض دول
المنطقه
وليس كما يتحدث الضيف من موسكو لا يوجد
القطاعات الامريكيه في مطار بغداد ولا
تفتش الطائرات الامريكيه الى بايدي عراقيه
هذه اخبار ملفقه نسمعها للاسف بين الحين
والاخر لا صحت ولا مصداقيه لها ولا
على المصلحه الوطنيه
عدم التدخل
تصديق مساله عدم تدخل ال ال التدخل اه
الانحياز العراق الى النظام السوري عندما
يعلم الجميع بان النظام العراقي اختار
يعني تبني مواقف في الجامعه العربيه وفي
مجلس الامن مؤيده للنظام السوري وان هناك
تصريحات رسميه
يعني حتى نتبع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والولايات المتحده القطريه حتى نكون
محايدين نحن سيدتي اخذنا مواقف متزنه نحن
لا نريد ان نلغي بالدم السوري اذا كان هذا
قرار بعض الدول العربيه فهذا ليس قرار
ننتقل
يعني ليس
ليس هذا موضوعنا ولكن دكتور علي فقط قبل
ان نمر الى الى الفاصل الرئيس الوزراء
العراقي نفسه عبر التلفزيون الرسمي
العراقي قال بالحرف الواحد ان ال العراق
يعارض بشده تغيير النظام في سوريا سنواصل
النقاش بعد وقفه قصيره ونعود اليكم
مشاهدينا فلا تذهب بعيدا
مشاهدينا اهلا وسهلا بكم من جديد الى
حلقتنا التي تتناول ا بعد زياره رئيس
الوزراء العراقي نوري المالكي الى موسكو
وزياده عن الملف السوري وملف اه وذلك
زياده على الملف السوري وملف ايضا صفقات
السلاح الذي تشتري العراق من موسكو هناك
حاجه لمزيد من ادراك الكيفيه التي يدير
بها العراق علاقته مع روسيا في ضوء
التزاماته وتحالفه مع واشنطن اريد ان
انتقل اه الى واشنطن من جديد والسفير جيمس
جيفري في هذا الجزء الثاني من البرنامج
نحاول اذا ان نتحدث عن التوازنات في
علاقات العراق مع الحليف الامريكي واشنطن
وايضا التقارب مع اه اه موسكو انتم في
واشنطن كيف تنظر الاداره الامريكيه الى
هذا التقارب العراقي الروسي
شكرا جزيلا اولا اود ان اوضح بعض الامور
ولو انني بشكل عام اتفق مع قاله ال
البرلمان العراقي قبل قليل العراق بلد ذو
سياده
وعلينا ان لا نقع كثيرا في الزيارات
الرسميه التي يقوم بها الايرانيون او
جنرالات امريكان او زياره رئيس الوزراء
الى مستوى لا تبقى هذه امور تحصل الدائم
ان ولا ينبغي اولا تحقق الكثير منها هذا
هذه اول شيء ان اقوله واما
هنا في واشنطن نفهم ان السيد المالكي لديه
علاقات
علاقه كما قال المتحدث نحن نشجع العلاقات
الجيده بين روسيا والعراق من بذلك عمل
روسيا في جنوب
في نفط الجنوب
ولكن كما قلت اننا لا اختلافنا هو ان لا
نرى امكانيه او فرصه لحل سلمي على الطرفين
لانه وسبب ذلك ان حكومه الاسد
هذا النظام يرفض التنحي لانه يحصل على دعم
من الخارج وخاصه من ايران ولكن الاسلحه
تصله من روسيا نحن نضع العراق في نفس
الشيعه العراقيون يعانون كثيرا وحلت
الفوضى في سوريا وبالتالي لديهم القلق
وبالتالي اعتقد موقفهم حيادي وهم يدعمون
الجناح المعتدل او الجناح ال المطالبه
من في الجامعه العربيه وفي الامم المتحده
اذا لم يخيب على علاقه منكم
ان الشيء الوحيد الذي اثار تقلقنا ولا
استطيع ان كل التفاصيل هناك نتعامل مع هي
الطائرات الايرانيه التي تمر فوق العراق
الى سوريا وقد حدث العراقيين حول ذلك ولكن
الموقف العراقي الذي سمعناه في الامم
المتحده في الجامعه اجتماعات الجامعه
العربيه او على الاقل انا عندما كنت انا
حاضرا في برنا تحلت
كانت مواقع ضمنا
التوافق الموجود في الجامعه العربيه
المتحده وبالتالي لم تكن مصدر القلق
بالنسبه لنا وكان وزير الخارجيه العراقي
قد اه حاول ان يخفف من القلق حول هذه
المساله ان ما قال ان الطائرات الايرانيه
اه يعني س تخضع للتفتيش في اه الاجواء
التي تمر عبر الاجواء العراقيه تخضع
للتفتيش لكن ليس هذا موضوعنا نتحدث الان
دكتور علي
توازنات العراق في علاقاتهما واشنطن مع
موسكو كيف تحافظ بغداد على هذا التوازن ما
حليف مهم وهو امريكا وايضا في ظل هذا
التقارب الجديد مع موسكو لحل الازمه
السوريه
اولا انا اعتقد ان العراق لم يكن ابدا اه
يعني في موقف الندا والضد لروسيا والصين
كانت علاقات جيده منذ سقوط الديكتاتوريه
مع كل اه الدول دول العالم والولايات
المتحده واوروبا الغربيه ثم الصين اليابان
كوريا روسيا نحن نعم قدرنا العراق ينبغي
ان يستفيد من اخطاء الدكتاتوريه وان نقيم
علاقات متوازنه مع الجميع وضمن ما نص عليه
الدستور العراقي في الاف من العراق ضمن
محور ما او تابعا بنفوذ العراق بلد مستقل
سيد يتمتع بعلاقات جيده مع الجميع بدءا
بدول الجوار وانتهاءا باقصى الاقصى في
العالم ولذلك هذه الزياره جاءت بناءا على
دعوه روسيه ولم تاتي بعد زياره وزير
خارجيه ايراني او قبل زياره رئيس ايراني
هذه الزياره مبرمجه في العلاقات الثنائيه
بين البلدين الصديقين
نحن نسعى الى ان تكون علاقتنا متوازنه
منفتحه اه تعتمد اه سياسه تقوم على احترام
المعايير الدوليه على احترام شرعه حقوق
الانسان وايضا على احترام مصالح العراق
ومصالح العراق فوق كل الاعتبارات الاخرى
ونحن نسعى باستمرار الى ان لا يدخل العراق
في اي مشكله دوليه دخول سلبيا لاننا جربنا
في العراق الحضور السلبي كما حصل في عده
مرات في الحرب مع ايران دوله الكويت في
امور اخرى عديده ولذلك استفدنا من هذه
التجربه ونريد ان تكون للعلاقه للعراق
علاقات جيده بالجميع
واضح الفكره اه اه لكن عندما تقول وسؤال
للاستاذ عباس خلال في موسكو عندما يقول
الدكتور عليش لا فان الزياره جاءت بطلب من
موسكو لرئيس الوزراء العراقي يزور روسيا
في حاملا معه ما يمكن اعتباره مبادره او
طرح سياسي لحل الازمه السوريه هل تكون
موسكو بصدد البحث عن يعني مخرج لرفع الحرج
عن تصل بها في مجلس الامن وبالتالي ايجاد
حل سياسي تقدمه العراق او يقدمه العراق
اه موسكو لا تشعر بالحرج فهي استخدمت
ثلاثه مرات قرار النقض الفيتو يبدو انه
موسكو ذاهبه الى النهايه في مساله دعم
النظام السوري الا اللهم حدث شيء ما او
خرق كبير السيد علي السلاح من بغداد من
يقول انه بدعوه من الحكومه
الروسيه طبعا رئيس وزراء لابد ان ياتي ب
دعوه رسميه والا كيف ياتي المساله المساله
المهمه اه ال الامريكيون كما ذكر السفير
الامريكي يقولون انها زيارات معينه
وزيارات بروتوكوليه ولا ينفذ اغلب اغلب ما
يتفق اثناء هذه الزيارات يبدو ان
الامريكان يسيطرون بشكل تام ويعرفون الى
ماذا الى مدى الحدود التي يذهب اليها
السيد المالكي والحكومه بغداد اعتقد ان
موسكو اظهرت براغماتيه كبيره في العوده
مره اخرى الى اه حقول النفط العراقيه وهي
ترى بانها استثمرت الكثير ولعل زياره اه
رئيس شركه لوك اويل الروسيه
وايضا قبل الزياره ولربما عده هو للزياره
والتي اخذت حقل غرب القرنه في البصره اه
يبدو ان موسكو ذهبت في برغم اتيت ها وهي
اللي ربما لديها حتى التنسيق اه في هذا
الجانب وتبادل الخبرات وتبادل المعلومات
مع الجانب الامريكي وهذا ليس مستبعدا حيث
انه اه اه موسكو
حتى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وهي في
هذه الازمه مع سوريا في اقامه اتصالات
بخصوص الاسلحه اه الاسلحه الكينيه ويعتقد
ان موسكو ذاهبه بشكل كبير على تلعب على
براغماتيا الى تعاون بشكل ناجح الى اه الى
مصالحه في العراق شكرا اشكرك اه الاستاذ
عباس خلف مستشار معهد الدراسات
الاستراتيجيه الروسيه كنت معنا من موسكو
واشكر ايضا من بغداد الدكتور عليش لا
النائب في مجلس النواب العراقي عن كتله
ائتلاف دوله القانون ومن واشنطن جيمس
جيفري السفير الامريكي السابق لدى العراق
شكرا لكم جميعا وبهذا في هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر ونلتقي غدا باذن
الله
ام
[موسيقى]